hey guys today we have a 2013 Nissan
Altima
we'll be using the auto pro pad
to program the smart key
this is all keys lost situation so this
is not programmed for the car
all right let's get to it
all right guys so let's get started so
you can see
this key is not registered
okay
all right
so what we're gonna do is
let's go ahead
go to the auto pro pad basic
let's go to
um
Nissan USA
agree
then let's go to program keys
let's go select from vehicle
Nissan
and Ultima sedan this is a sedan
as you can see we got one
and door in the back
press the sedan
2013 so that's where we're gonna click
Smart Key Program smart keys
so it says switch ignition off
ignition is off
turn the hazard warning lights press OK
so let's
positive warning lights
and press ok
all smart key will be erased you can
program up to four smart key total all
right yes
steering wheel in release date press yes
to continue
it is released as you can see it's not
locked
press yes
do not press the brakes press and hold
the start button until the ignition turn
is on
just say that press and hold it until on
that is on
okay
press ok
switch the ignition off press ok to
continue
press it once
and that is off again
let's
okay
press and release the start button with
the logo of the key which is this is the
logo of the key to the center of the
bond if the vehicle Charmed twice and
the ignition
switches on the key was accepted
the immobilizer indication would also
flash five times if the vehicle Chimes
six more times the ignition remains is
off it's not accepted so
press yes to continue
if the key was accepted and the ignition
is on press yes all right so we're going
to use this
logo
to hold it
and it turned on then release
so that's accepted
dropped my program hold on
you press ok
yes
if the immobilizer
see what it says
indication is off press yes to continue
otherwise is fail
it's on so press OK yes
switch switch the ignition off press ok
to continue
press that again turn it off
that's off
then okay to continue
all right program success would you like
to program any additional key now we
only have one key to program just press
no
press the start button with the logo of
the key introduced successfully
the vehicle will chime server time
ignition
should switch on
switch the ignition off
and the instrumental cluster should
press key
registration complete
program okay
let's press this
turn on
see that
and then
turn it off
press one
press ok
open the door
that should be good let me try it
let's try it again
there you go
press it on
just one more time
there you go
and beep pressed it
key registration complete so I just have
to turn on and off
with the key on the button
and try it there you go
lock and unlock
so you can see
that's program already
we can turn off the hazard and just
start the car press the brake pedal
there you go
there you go guys
that's easy
programming all keys lost
and um
using the um AutoPro pad
turn it off again
put it right outside
and try to turn it on
thing it says key ID incorrect so you
can see
and you have
to have a ski inside your car
there you go
and everything works
lock
unlock
here
to exit everything
and that's what we have
using the auto pro pad
what we have is a
let's see if you can see is the auto pro
pad basic
you can't even see it
put a light on it hold on
there you go
it's the auto pro pad basic key
programmer
and that's what we use
to
um program the key
all right let's try to start again
press the brake
guys
and that's how you program it
pretty easy in less than 10 minutes you
could probably do it in five minutes
and all right
thank you for watching
I hope you like this video
and don't forget to like And subscribe
for more video
alright guys thank you until next time